how's it going bros my name is beard
today me and my friend Jack and Mark are
playing World of Warcraft I used to play
this game so much so this is a bit of a
trip to the past because the Warcraft
movie is coming out the 10th of June
we're super excited and Mark is gonna
teach us how to play the game properly
because I forgot and Jack never played
it typical Irish piece of [ __ ] now I've
been told a couple things number one you
want to see the movie go watch it in
IMAX to get the full scope of the
experience of the epicness number two
the core idea of the movie is dispara
t'v heroes having to unite together in
order I don't care does it have action
in it I'm in number 4 director Duncan
Jones is a gamer a huge gamer and he has
a unique vision to make the movie come
to life from what I heard they really
made the game come to life and that
makes me excited so without further ado
let's play some warcraft mrs. bumble
flat yes bumble flap yeah what do you
want how do we play the game oh you guys
don't know no we don't know anything
teach us wait wait we're going to sleep
and listen we're shooting off a lot of
green radiation at the moment and that
means do you want me to give you a lore
lesson on why we're irradiated yes
please yeah wait a while I thought we
were farting butt--okay oh oh yeah ah no
make it stop kill me you should have
known now for the three of us if they
should have known that mmm mmm wait what
how do you live a lot cuz I'm better
than you
[ __ ] man I'm supposed to be a teacher
good point okay we have to you're a
warrior
alright scream hey I'm shut up everybody
shut up look out for the eggs
oh my god oh my god you're so dumb stop
ever you need to do it why am I not
level 100 yet ah you need to exit the
game
aim booster chair watters okay I thank
you for teaching is a great teacher mark
I think we're ready for level hunter now
I agree I think the boys really deserve
an upgrade so if you leave you'll notice
no no no we should do a leveling up
montage and pretend we did all the work
oh okay
whoa I'm so [ __ ] cool
holy [ __ ] I got a [ __ ] Gryphon
how do I fly fly you stupid son of a
[ __ ] going to the Stormwind portal up
here I'm going to storm in holy Sh oh
we're going to go to stormy can we go -
go go - go - higher oh my god yes I saw
my first pair of boobs and gold Shire
got great memories oh my god Jack
actually this is hilarious because on
roleplay servers gold Shire is known as
like the place the orgy village hahahaha
I'm not joking like all the characters
go to Gold chart and they have
role-playing four G's in gold Shire - we
should go
yeah whoa wait this is [ __ ] cool yeah
just follow me the mountains right over
here you get to fly over see all the
cool vistas this is where the movies
gonna take place you remember in the
trailer you saw the flyover blah blah
huh I don't know much about Warcraft so
I want to know as much as possible for a
movie okay well this is Stormwind
it's where the humans live the base of
it so if you keep following my white dot
hey that's right like that's what she's
it's been ages ages since I've been in
this area and you never feel explan ha
ha ha I remember the burning steps I
remember this place yeah holy [ __ ] the
nostalgia oh that's you this is where I
didn't stick see guys this is where I
got sixty
yeah IIM sixty here - yeah it was just
finding ogres like oh those [ __ ]
ogres man so many organs too many ways
yeah those augers am i right hey [ __ ]
you those ogres were it oh you'll never
understand gays date a 59 to 60 do you
know what a big deal II was to get your
first Mount
I went off I had I had to borrow gold
from one of my me - I never paid him
back
I'm same uh I remember I died here once
and I got so [ __ ] pissed that I
didn't even know what to do now
Oh God don't touch the eggs touch the
eggs jack it's cool it's like a cold
laughing oh my god he just ran in here's
where things get complicated because
this actually takes some strategy see
the big blue stream up there and the orb
on the left that that orc is touching
one of us has to touch that orb and then
control that dragon on the right his
name is razor door dips and edge
controlling dragon Oh Oh God
what the [ __ ] did you do you crazy Irish
game we're doing it oh my god I'll kill
razor core I think no not ready hepta
okay oh I'm rolling need on everything
oh yeah [ __ ] you I'm rolling now my epic
loot yeah Oh [ __ ] I remember I
played paladin and that would need on
everything because I'm like well I could
need that for healing well I could need
that for tanking Jack like try to
imagine 40 people literally 40 people Oh
God forty people we flying through this
dungeon coordinating everyone doing like
500 damage it was usually just one guy
who was like 20 and a bunch of 13
year-olds can you imagine handling that
mini 13 year-olds hey we do it every
bank chess piece than they a lot of
people doing stupid okay what did you
say dude if you saw me then with the
whole thing you'll be like oh my [ __ ]
god that's a rad chest yeah you had the
shoulder pads did anybody get the
shoulder pad then I got the shitty ones
are you making a girl or a boy girl is
everyone making a girl oh man so many
memories and go shower oh my god
yeah uh yeah the party hell yeah I'm
doing the Macarena
I'm much harder excuse me I am much
harder I think I'm the hottest he said
we must go wait I'm not naked when you
talk about nothing it's oh yeah sorry
uh just don't move so I can mute don't
don't
uh Oh got one got one yeah damn it I
remember when you play this game like if
you had a female character everyone
would be so much nicer to you who knows
this is a very interesting place guys
this is getting weird man I don't I feel
weird I don't
all right breasts hope you enjoyed this
video if you did go ahead and leave a
like I really always appreciate it check
out the movie June 10th they supposed to
have a ton of Easter eggs and cool stuff
like that for you Warcraft fans are you
excited let me know what you think of
that and as always stay awesome
Oh Tony Hawk right now huh guess we got
some scrub skateboarders over here
cadet skate with you guys come on